He's back in smiles. He's just, well, the thing is Johnny says,
yeah, I can get away with things because, uh, they call me Chrissy charms.
Cause I can charm, but charms going away though. If my CalPERS,
Glen getting smaller and my charms going away, I think my CalPERS gland,
he tends to go with the bed. My charm lives in my CalPERS, Glen,
and they're shrinking. So it's just what it is.
How did they find that they had to do, um,
they go in through the front camera up your D dude. No, no, no.
So what happened was, is I had got a girl who was on birth control, pregnant,
and then that's like almost impossible. Well,
not if you've got a hyperactive calipers
came, we Blitzkrieg that.
No CAS wait, sorry. So, um,
so they couldn't believe that I got this girl pregnant and blah, blah, blah,
blah. So they did tests on you. The doctor's like just throw a test. So I,
I go in, uh, to donate sperm and they're like, do you want prostate?
Or do you want to, do you want, do you want to or do you,
a nurse can come in and do give you a prostate exam? I was like, no.
And then did they really say that, you know,
that's the option a nurse can do it without you having to do anything.
They go in and they touch your prostate or massage. It's not. Yeah.
It's just comes out. I don't even believe that it's a real it's it's science.
Yeah. So they do that or that's the address or you could drop off. Yeah.
They had magazines. So you could jerk off, he jerked off. You're like,
bring me a bucket. Yeah. Just fun. A mag bang. Yeah. So,
so this episode is just becoming about Chrissy's com yeah.
I think this is the most minutes we've done about your, yeah.
We're going to talk about JFK's assassination. Well,
that guy left come anywhere anyway. Yeah. Talking about your tonsils, your,
your prostate exam,
and your kids want to know that's what they want to dig into.
Magic bullets. [inaudible]
yeah. Um, so, um, so,
so then I get my sperm looked at and the doctors say that it's like four or five
times the amount of normal sperm. So they're like the million dollar man. Yeah.
They, at first they thought that I was born. They didn't,
they wanted to verify that I was born in Queens and I wasn't adopted from Russia
because they thought I was potentially born in a Trenoble radiation zone,
which is wild. Um, that would explain some stuff. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Cause that's a common side effect over there. Yeah.
Well they have all the locations.
They have all types of mutations that wasn't an HBO series. I didn't say. Yeah.
He left that part out. It's got bags out. Some dogs just leave the shots at him.
So, so they said, um, they said, uh, you know,
they want it to like look further because they're like, you know,
it could be just like an abnormality or it could have like a tumor or something
like that. So they just did like an MRI and they looked and they saw like,
how big the CalPERS Glenn? Wasn't like, Oh, this is the problem. Like,
you're fine. It's just like, you know, just a seven, just shoot out these ropes.
Yeah. Did you ever see that? Do you ever see those guys,
those people that suffer from that orgasm, uh,
disease where they just cry all the time? Yeah.
Like you'll be talking to me like, yeah. But so does even shoot? No,
it's just, it's just organic. Yeah. It'd be like rounding. I mean,
I was going to say you ever jerk out four times in one day,
but obviously not with no, no, no I don't.
But sometimes when you get the flu in like sixth grade and you're like,
I'm just gonna beat this thing to hell. The fourth time hurts.
It hurts everything. It's a burn genital arousal disorder. Yeah.
So they get like a Rouse from walking and like anything touches it. They just,
they just coming hard wind. And it's actually like, it hurts.
It's like a problem. It's like very painful. He came,
he came blood in the beginning of the year, uh, two years ago. Yeah.
This calendar year. What are we talking about? [inaudible]
started off in some blood speed out how much? Just a little bit.
And then enough to notice enough to, yeah.
That all you need is a little to be like, what's up walk.
How scared were you though in that moment? Scary drive cancer everywhere.
We wrote a whole Bay Ridge boys up episode because I was,
it was based off kid came. His glue was a bloody. I had to go to a,
you go get your, you get,
get the finger in the butt to see if the prostate is okay.
And apparently it's okay. Apparently. What did the doctor say to you?
To the pro? He goes, sorry. Uh, he goes, sorry, kid or whatever.
It was like, he, when he goes in like, cause you just,
like you bent over the gay guys are real, man, man. They just like do that.
Like it's an uncomfortable feeling.
Like you gotta be in the men to want something in your. Yeah.
Cause he was just in there and he saw, I just kind of was like,
I was just dealing just winsome a little bit. He was just like, sorry, kid,
what you do knuckle? Or like first knuckle, they go two fingers in there. Right?
Like, well it depends what kind of hands, if you have a white,
if you have a wide center to finger, poke it right in the butt.
I guess they go one index finger over like,
they're trying to press the elevator button, but you didn't come. Huh?
You didn't come. Not this time. But this was the third prostate exam.
I've had three, two. Yeah. They just touch the bladder right there.
Or they just touch the prostate and then shoot your glue out.
And that little thing under the bladder, I believe is the CalPERS, Glen.
And that's where my thing is just huge. That's why just shoot glue out of,
he's got like an Andre, the giant. We are really in this word. We're in there.
Yeah.
I mean I love how they put a glove on the car car to request.
Yeah. I'll tell you the glove with his wedding ring on. I tell you this.
Yeah.
We'll be talking about JFK's assassination and we just have a picture of the
record. It's what happens on this podcast? This podcast is hyena.
It'll all make its way around. Well, eventually, you know what? I,
my mom looked like JFK's wife, Jacqueline Kennedy, Onassis.
She looks like her people would today stop in the street. No, they, my mom,
when she was young, she used to say that people would stop her in the street.
My father verified this and they thought she was Jacqueline Kennedy Onassis.
And we call her Jackie O like Jackie. Oh yeah. My mom looks just like her.
She does a little bit. No,
this woman saw her husband's face get blown off. Yeah.
I think she tried to put it back together too. If you watch the video,
like then she really,
she gathers his skull and it's like trying to like put it back on his head.
I did Opie and Anthony with the, um, I think his name was Clint black.
And he wrote a book.
He was the secret service agent that when you watch the video,
he jumps in the back of your car. Was he the one that got shot?
He didn't get shot. He didn't get shot. I forgot the guy who got shot.
But anyway, w we did a whole three hour interview.
I was just the other guest on Opie and Anthony, when they did this.
And he was saying that when he jumped in the back, like, you know,
you have to take, it's a whole procedure. He he's like,
you have to take him to the hospital and tell the American people that we tried
everything Kenny. So when he, he was pretty much decapitated, dead,
like eyes in the back. Like he was dead. Like he said, the first shot,
like by the time or the second shot, like he was, there was no saving him.
It was pointless. Take him to the hospital. Yeah. He said it was just like,
it was all. And he said,
he believes this guy believes that being there, how quick everything happened.
He said he doesn't think for a second at Lee Harvey Oswald killed him. Well,
that's what these races, these boys solve it today. You guys, you guys told us,
you have the answer. What happened? I know what happened.
Let we can get back to the rest shot. Let's get back to relax after that. Um,
I'm probably going to disappear into this episode with each other's fingers and
all our asphalts yet. Let's do it. Let's check each other's prostate.
I just learned about this little magic button in the backseat. Absolutely. Yeah.
Well, you're going to really learn about it tonight after the pot. Yeah.
We're going to take some perfect 10 and put on pretty woman and you're going to
get cracked in my love. What's going to happen.